and my name is kimberly estrada
today i am with a group called
dreamweaver which is a group of the
trimmers and also with you will deny success
which is a youth group well
because i have seen how it
gets when people don't vote there are a lot of
people  There are local voters who make
decisions for us that
really do impact our lives and well,
I want everyone from the
communities to come to say in their
own voice what they want
and yes, so that everything  in
our community it changes for the better
good
[Music]
yes good our groups are they don't seem
they are not with any no party and
we have seen republicans we have
seen people who came to vote for
president trump we have seen people who
say they come to vote  for
democrats and that they only vote for
democrats but everything was all with
great respect and there was no plot and
luckily there are no lines
so they still have that it's fine
Quick, it's very easy for people to
come to vote
[Music]
of this election. For me, since I'm
with James' organization and because
I have a lot of people, my family who are
immigrants, I'm excited because a
lot of people come who also
they have relatives who are immigrants and they
come with that in mind and they come
not only to vote for themselves but
to vote for the trimmers who
can't and well that gives me how they didn't
know each other in Spanish like hop
that everything will be fine  for
the first ones
yes thank you